i've lived in hong kong since 1992
and i'm now planning on leaving
hong kong has changed irrevocably it's
not going to go back to
what it was and we've seen
the best days and you know has
[Music]
accentuated that feeling that
this is the right time to go
so this is what i looked like
30-yard years ago it's probably 28 years
ago or so actually young
smart still had hair
and i do remember
the scaffolding on nathan road
with all the neon at night and it was a
very very atmospheric
and it just reminded me so much of blade
runner hong kong was such a
free-wheeling you know
free society people really have no
filter in like
how they express themselves when you
look at the media
as it used to be very kind of vigorous
and you know we are here in the fcc and
this is where i have my first
journalism interview so that this this
place has a certain significance for me
something that i wouldn't forget easily
so this is chunking mansions this is the
first place i came to when i got off the
plane
the place to come or certainly used to
be if you want a fake rolex watch or a
cheap curry or indeed a cheap dormitory
bed
just really hasn't changed at all
so
to my memory anyway
i think one of the striking things about
hong kong is just
how you have these extremes of wealth
you've got chunking mansions
which is
you know one end of the scale and you
literally cross the road and you go to
the most august grand hotel in hong kong
first time i came to the peninsula was
when i was sent here to interview james
tierne a local business figure and
politician
his secretary said to me he'll meet you
in the peninsula and i said where's that
and his secretary laughed at me and said
you're working in hong kong and you
don't know where the peninsula is
so
that was my first visit here i didn't
realize i had been living opposite it
when i after i first arrived in hong
kong but in a quite different
environment
hong kong when i arrived here was in the
middle of a massive economic boom
the city was sort of brimming over with
nervous anxiety that everyone was in a
hurry to make money
to get foreign passports to move out or
you know at least have a root out
well of course there's the handover
itself from 97
you know the sovereignty had changed it
was now part of china again life just
really kind of carried on as normal
quite interesting to see just
you know how the skyline has changed
there's a lot of new buildings it's kind
of interesting that the hong kong
convention and exhibition center over
there
hadn't been built the land that that
stands on was also sea at the time
uh that's where they held the handover
ceremony 25 years ago
i think there was a more of a sense of
possibility when i arrived in 92 you
know things were still kind of growing
fast
china was sort of in some ways still
kind of getting started
and i think as hong kong got richer and
rich and rich obviously and the young
people the younger generation
particularly don't
seem to feel that sense of possibility
that was there 25 30 years ago
the biggest change by far
was the passing under national security
law two years ago
this time you know all the
apprehension about
what might happen after 1997
the things that people feared have
already happened
i see the 25th anniversary as being
you know something quite sombre really i
think for most people in hong kong when
we know the majority of people in hong
kong
supported democracy wanted to see why
the democracy here
and those hopes have been
seemingly
conclusively
crushed now
i don't think that people fundamentally
have changed i think they're the same
and the many things i love about the way
hong kong people are resilience
adaptability
and never say die attitude and also kind
of humor and irreverence as well
i mean i will miss hong kong as many
things i'll miss about hong kong
[Music]